en el vídeo anterior les presentemos un
ejercicio de optimización con
restricciones donde estábamos tratando
de maximizar esta función de dos
variables x cuadrada james y estaba
sujeta a esta restricción a la
restricción que sus valores x james
tienen que satisfacer esta ecuación que
tengo aquí que es el círculo unitario y
la manera en la que estábamos
visualizando esto era observar el tano x
gem donde este círculo de aquí
representaba nuestra restricción todos
los puntos que conforman ese conjunto
son los puntos que están en el círculo
unitario y luego esta curva de aquí es
una de las curvas de nivel de f
es decir estábamos definiendo una f de
xy que fuera igual a una cierta
constante y luego estábamos modificando
esa constante cm para ver cuáles sean
los valores más altos que aguantaba ser
tales que la curva se viera así este es
el valor donde x cuadrada por james es
el más grande es el máximo y luego para
valores pequeños deseemos las curvas se
verían más o menos
así que todos los puntos en esta línea
serían efe de x james igual a 2 en
digamos 0.01 en este caso o algo así
ahora la manera de pensar en maximizar
esta función es intentar aumentar ese
valor de ser tanto como se pueda sin que
se salga del círculo y la solución clave
es que esto ocurre cuando son tangentes
así que ya saben si me permiten dibujar
por aquí un boceto y pongo por aquí la
línea del círculo que por cierto ya
sabes que representa la curva de la
restricción que en este caso saben que
es el círculo unitario y por aquí dibujo
a la curva del nivel entonces observamos
que cuando se pesan estas dos curvas
cuando apenas apenitas se tocan es
cuando esta función se maximiza ahora en
términos de resolver el problema aún
tenemos algo de trabajo que hacer y la
principal herramienta que aquí vamos a
usar es el gradiente así que vamos a
dibujar por aquí unas cuantas curvas del
nivel más de las que ya están para x
cuadrada y así que estas son muchas
muchas curvas de nivel y voy a dibujar
el campo gradiente de f
el campo gradiente de efe es este que
tenemos aquí y anteriormente hizo un
vídeo acerca de la relación entre el
gradiente y las curvas de nivel la
conclusión de eso es que estos vectores
gradientes cada vez que pasan a través
de una curva del nivel son
perpendiculares a esa curva del nivel la
razón básica para eso es que si caminan
a lo largo de una curva del nivel
entonces la función no está cambiando de
valor así que si quieren cambiar más
rápidamente tiene sentido que deberían
de caminar en la dirección perpendicular
de modo que ningún componente de la
caminata que estemos tomando sea inútil
ya que ésta está a lo largo de la línea
donde la función no cambia pero de nuevo
hay un vídeo completo de eso que vale la
pena ver si todo esto no les parece
conocido ahora para nuestros propósitos
esto lo que significa es que si nos
fijamos justo aquí en el punto de
tangencia entonces el gradiente
va a hacer un vector perpendicular a
ambas curvas este de aquí le podemos
decir el gradiente de efe y podemos ser
algo muy parecido para entender la otra
curva esta que tenemos aquí por ahora
solamente la tenemos como x cuadrada más
de cuadrada igual a 1 pero podemos
bautizar a esta función de la siguiente
manera le puedo poner el nombre de eje
de xy igual a equis cuadrada más 10
cuadrada y bueno observa que
prácticamente las curvas de nivel para
esta función
se ven más o menos así si vamos al plano
y vemos todas las demás curvas de nivel
para esta función g se ven como círculos
y esto debería tener mucho sentido ya
que observan aquí tenemos una función g
que nos está definiendo un círculo y si
observamos el gradiente de gm es decir
nos acercamos nos preguntamos por el
gradiente de g éste tiene la misma
propiedad que cada vector gradiente pasa
de manera perpendicular a la curva de
nivel
y entonces podemos decir que en este
dibujo de aquí si me fijo en el
gradiente de gm también se va a ver
perpendicular a estas dos curvas ahora
ustedes saben que tal vez no sean del
mismo largo que el gradiente df pero va
a ir en la misma dirección este de aquí
es el gradiente de g ojo no hay razón
por la cual tenga la misma longitud que
el gradiente de f puede ser más pequeño
o más largo pero lo importante es que es
proporcional y la manera en la que vamos
a escribir las fórmulas es decir que
este gradiente de f evaluado en
cualquiera que sea su valor que
optimicen a esta función x cuadrada
james no será si quieres le podemos
poner algún nombre especial este
gradiente de f evaluado en una equis que
maximicen james que maximice
esto tiene que ser igual a algo por el
gradiente de lambda ojo no van a ser
iguales por acá voy a poner al gradiente
de lambda y bueno no voy a poner que son
iguales por aquí me falta algo pero este
gradiente evaluado también en esta x m
coma
es decir me estoy fijando en este valor
que está maximizando esta función efe y
como dije no son iguales son
proporcionales y es por eso que tenemos
que multiplicar por algún tipo de
constante de proporcionalidad y casi
siempre se usa la variable lambda y
bueno se usa la variable lambda con un
nombre muy rimbombante esta lambda se le
conoce como el multiplicador de lagrange
lagrange fue uno de esos famosos
matemáticos franceses que yo siempre con
fundó con otros matemáticos franceses de
la misma época como legendre o la plaza
pero en este caso si estamos hablando de
lagrange entonces este es el
multiplicador de lagrange y bueno es que
hay muchas cosas en cálculo
multivariable nombradas en honor a la
granxa y esta es una de las grandes
porque esta técnica la desarrolló el o
por lo menos la popularizó y la idea
central es definir los gradientes df y
los gradientes deben proporcionales
entre sí ya que esto representa cuando
la curva del nivel
la función f es tan gente a la curva del
nivel para la función g así que esta
expresión que tengo aquí en realidad
podemos trabajarla y vamos a empezar con
el gradiente de gm si me fijo en mi
gradiente de gm éste va a ser igual
bueno al gradiente de la función g qué
es esto es decir al gradiente de x
cuadrada más cuadrada ahora recordemos
que significa tener este gradiente de
esta función bueno eso significa tomarme
un vector que en la primera componente
tengamos la derivada parcial de esta
función con respecto a x y bueno si
observas la derivada de esta función con
respecto a x es 2 x 2x y después esta
parte de aquí sería constante como no
tiene x su derivada de 0 y en la segunda
componente vamos a tomarnos la derivada
parcial de esta función g pero esta vez
con respecto a iu y si te das cuenta
ahora esto es lo que es constante
la derivada de esto con respecto a evans
es una constante y a eso le sumamos 2
y entonces este es el vector gradiente
para mi función que que es justo esta
parte de aquí ahora vamos a fijarnos en
el gradiente de la función
efe entonces si por acá cálculo el
gradiente de la función efe este va a
ser el gradiente de esta función x
cuadrada james el gradiente de la
función x cuadrada bien aquí y vamos a
hacer lo mismo va a ser un vector que en
la primera componente tenga la derivada
parcial de esta función con respecto a x
bueno la derivada de x cuadrada es 2x y
esto es una constante cuando derivamos
con respecto a x entonces me quedaría 2
y recuerda cuando derivamos con respecto
a x ésta se ve como una constante como
un número entonces me quedarían 2x james
y en la segunda componente nos vamos a
tomar la derivada parcial de esta
función efe
pero ahora con respecto a ella y eso me
quedaría bueno la derivada de ye con
respecto y es 11 por equis cuadrada es
simplemente x cuadrada entonces aquí
está ya tenemos también el vector del
gradiente df y ahora déjenme bajar la
pantalla para que podamos seguir con
esta ecuación que tienen al
multiplicador de lagrange porque de esta
ecuación que tengo aquí podemos obtener
lo siguiente podemos obtener que el
gradiente de efe que es esto que tenemos
aquí déjame ponerlo es
2x y 2x y en la primera componente en la
segunda componente de cuadrada esto
tiene que ser igual a lambda veces el
gradiente deje a lambda veces el
gradiente de g que también ya tenemos
por acá lambda veces el gradiente de g
que eran 2x y aquí 2
ok y entonces observamos que esto nos da
dos ecuaciones ahora mismo es una sola
ecuación con vectores pero en realidad
lo que esto nos está diciendo es que
tenemos dos ecuaciones separadas y las
podemos escribir así la primera sería
déjame ponerlo así 2x y 2
igual a lambda veces x 2x igual a lambda
veces x 2x y la otra ecuación sería x
cuadrada x cuadrada igual a landa veces
x 2 y lambda veces 2 ya lo voy a poner
con su respectivo color tantas veces 2
y esto podría parecer un ejercicio
difícil de resolver porque observan
tenemos dos ecuaciones y tres incógnitas
y tal vez puedas pensar que nos estamos
metiendo el pie solitos porque obtenemos
una nueva variable con la cual lidiar
pero observan aunque aquí solamente
tenemos dos ecuaciones y necesitamos
tres ecuaciones para resolver estas tres
incógnitas tenemos por acá una tercera
ecuación y esta tercera ecuación es algo
que hemos sabido todo este tiempo ha
sido parte del problema original y es
simplemente la ecuación de restricción
recuerdas la ecuación de restricción me
dice que estas x tienen que cumplir
x cuadrada más cuadrada debe de ser
igual a 1 entonces lo voy a anotar por
aquí x cuadrado
más que cuadrada
esto tiene que ser igual a 1 y con esto
observa ya tenemos 3 ecuaciones que
describen nuestro ejercicio de
optimización con restricciones estas 3
ecuaciones la ecuación del fondo x
cuadrada mayor cuadrada es igual a 1 nos
dice que tenemos que estar en este en
este círculo unitario y luego las dos
que tenemos aquí está ahí están nos
dicen que es necesario a fin de cuentas
que nuestra curva de nivel la curva de
epm y la curva de g sean perfectamente
tangentes entre sí
entonces en el siguiente vídeo voy a
continuar y resolver este ejercicio que
tengo aquí en este punto es bastante
álgebra como la que vamos a estar
trabajando pero vale la pena hacerla
para adentrarnos en la solución y luego
en los siguientes vídeos vamos a hablar
acerca de una manera en la que pueden
encapsular estas tres expresiones en una
sola expresión y además un poco acerca
de la interpretación de esta lambda que
en realidad no solamente es una variable
boba ésta tiene un significado bastante
interesante
con textos físicos sobre todo cuando
realmente estás trabajando con un
ejercicio de práctica de optimización
con restricciones entonces nos vemos en
el siguiente vídeo